[Music]
in WoW wows us there by none do we know
where my [ __ ] ain't none when you're
busy no no me ain't none of your
business
would have been it right there yeah well
that's why don't do this don't know why
even try to I'm [ __ ] played myself
though 70% of it there alright thank you
a woman's quest to grow the world's
largest but is sucking the Internet but
you can't row a but let me work out and
eat and work out and eat like that kind
of girl like let me eat eat eat GE and
then move that fat to my butt oh my god
like surgically surgically remove the
[ __ ] how do you do that you just squeeze
the top of your body line like a
toothpaste bottle of [ __ ] I wish oh
there's there's those like super big
people that are so fat and obese that
they had to cut the wall to get him out
take him to them they have the biggest
butt in the world there's some people
that are so fat that Kenny was SWAT the
mosquitos that are biting my legs so
wide you got sad because it turned you
on a little it's sad it's sad but
they're like I was watching this show
where they were showing it and it was
supposed to be a sad moment yeah but I
was in tears laughing and I just looked
at myself and I was like that is really
messed up David there's that c'mere next
to you yeah like stop it's because she
was so mad at his wife and his wife was
there and she was like I guess she left
the screen door open and the mosquitos
were biting his legs his fat legs but
she he could have reached them cuz he's
so bad you think it's funny
crying cuz she's so sad but that I
couldn't stop laughing cuz I had to bro
come on man you can't just what do this
you could do this you're so big
dude that's like being pregnant to you
though it's hard yeah after a while
you're just like God Dennis I know how
that felt when I was bulking I had a
really hard time tying my shoes and then
when I did I'd be out of breath I'm like
[ __ ]
it was hard [ __ ] this is really hard yes
this woman her name is Natasha cram
she's a model in Sweden and she is very
committed to have the largest ass in the
world this is what she looked like
before she oh she is
hey Jackie gunpei looks kind of big tall
big jokes
let's just go so does she look like
before she started doing all the body
she looks like she's like six something
she has a good body she looks normal
oh oh it's like a [ __ ] there's like
no back
it's just shoulders and ass so she just
keeps taking the fat injecting it back
in there she keeps doing I think she
said she's had three brazilian butt-lift
which is where they remove the fat from
one part of your body that's why her
waist is so skinny look at her lips dude
it's what her legs she's gotta work that
legs that reminds me of those ladies
that are addicted to getting implants
bigger and just doing the QQ challenge
your booty in action that's crazy
you're gonna like bus is that chair than
a halt I think she did that on purpose
she's trying to show how bigger but I'm
so big she's gonna get up it's gonna
stick hey someone's getting off on this
right now they're like damn girl
wow that's a big block guys want to see
what it looks like yeah she can't even
hang out with me outside that's pretty
hot that's just the insane a weird photo
chef like it looks like someone like
took the sideling melted themself I'm
not a guy but that's a hot angle but any
angle like that's hot though yeah ass is
so big her vaginas gone too
[ __ ] that ass you have to [ __ ] spread
and literally dirty chicks are gonna be
on your stomach yeah you need if you
guys spread like this and then her butt
cheeks are gonna be here like clamping
on you I can't wear the multi stomach
pad yes that's a big booty dude oh my
god you know what it's like it's like
two of these yeah it's like it's like
this and then it's it's like you get two
of these get your dick in there [ __ ]
you gotta split the ass cheeks like this
and then go through like that my dick
ain't big enough no for sure it's not
it's just gonna touch the surface it's
not gonna touch it this isn't gonna hair
it's just gonna be like here do you guys
want I guess what that's it come we
don't even have a bit like like this
long sir and it's probably just gonna be
the [ __ ] head going in and out ten
centimeters on no feet this is a
circumference six feet but I'm thinking
like seven feet six feet I like the
natural booty a man like cuz when you
have a magic what is it feet six feet no
natural booty makes sense because the
legs will match up to the proportions
right yeah it's not proportionate it's
like even a bodybuilding man there's not
proportionate people in a minute I feel
like some people don't know to look for
that what do you think was what kind of
[ __ ] that she saw before she did that
because you know in her like first photo
she looked fine like dudes nope she
didn't seem like she needed a bigger but
it looked like her booty could have been
big already well she says herself like
well maybe I have body dysmorphia but
maybe think you do maybe you do but I
just don't think it's big enough look
how pretty she was then before she's
obsessed can we go back to her you know
that's crazy
she's like this looks way better there
yeah she's not up to her own standard
yeah she said that when she started
developing when she was younger that she
just loved our body she loved the way
like everything he was just getting
bigger and bigger
yes and people will continue to make it
bigger and bigger I know some girls like
that you just got one bigger like I want
a big stomach yeah like that though
there's some people I know some girls
that are like I won't bigger trap so I
want bigger biceps
I want pecs like muscles though yeah not
like fat I mean but it's just bigger in
general so I can see them that mindset I
want I want to see some [ __ ] that's like
different though like I want a big job I
want a long like I want to look like a
[ __ ] Jay Leno but you have seen that
there's the guys that want to become
like fairies and [ __ ] oh and you get the
that's still that's still like I can
kind of see it cuz it's like an animal
or something cool like I want to see
some life I want I want big [ __ ]
years like Dumbo you know like I wanna
nose like Pinocchio like I wanna I want
just the [ __ ] longest forearm ever
just this right that's it yes
unrelatable things yeah that's what I
want to see oh wait traps there's art
there are people like that yeah there
are they're a big trash on a huge
distance between my nose in my upper lip
yeah it is this much distance stretch it
stretch it
let's give you extra skin now with the
skin graft Richard L because even
Coneheads are not that weird to me
because they do that skull-fucking
elongation thing yes going okay ahead of
the neck both that's I've seen it before
I just want to see some next-level [ __ ]
Oh check it out yeah it's called alien
ism it'sit's called uh skull [ __ ]
finding I think it's called skull
binding do you don't they start when
they're young too though and they just
like wrap it tight ahead gosh it was
born every baby oh like a bullet
like an ancient yeah yeah I think it's
my Inn or some [ __ ] now I thought you
might like today like right now they're
still doing it are they I don't think so
but they do do the [ __ ] giraffe neck
in Thailand they do that [ __ ] yeah dude
looking like an uncircumcised dick on
the head you know how I like back in the
day I don't they do it anymore but it'd
be tied if they did playboy they had
different countries so they highlight
the beauty of that country then you can
see like what is the hot naked conehead
people look like the hot naked stretch
neck people look like cuz I don't know
if they do that anymore I don't think
but it's a more like globalist like
culture now like every like everything
isn't like separated because of the
internet and like no I kind of set I
know that's what I don't like style is
the same now no matter where the [ __ ]
you go I wish people just kept it like
their [ __ ] till now imagine seeing
Instagram but then like Japan's like all
[ __ ] kimonos and [ __ ]
China's like all that Silk Road kung fu
outfit [ __ ] you know I mean like and
everything else is like that culture
like a thousand percent yeah because
everyone just wears lingerie like the
same lingerie you could buy them the
same store now yeah just like even like
beauty perception in Korea till to here
so different like right now the hot
thing in Japan and Korea is extremely
extremely pale face even for like normal
standards and then they want to be
transparent and then light pink lipstick
right now well it's not even the whole
thing it's just the middle part yeah it
just looks
they look like geishas like that's like
the thing right now yeah and even like
just a circle of yeah I even Mariel
because Mario's like she's like Fabi
Korean kind of yeah I look at like the
the models that are on like this like
when we go to a grocery market or a
Korean grocery market you'll see like
the models I look at them like man that
looks weird like wait Tama they're
they're pretty as hell I'm like
sometimes I look at him like why you
want to get with that
she looks 12 yeah I mean that's it's so
weird like even her perception of what
she thinks is pretty is way different
from life comfortably different well
hers is more like Korean yeah I mean
like very very pale super scrawny like
she thinks that's pretty and I know I
don't know I feel like obviously it's
your surroundings right well you're
constantly seeing so it's like through
osmosis I guess yeah it kind of happens
that way cuz there's that like those
Korean guys that are very scrawny and
pale and they kind of look very
effeminate for American standards and
she goes that's a handsome guy I'm like
in what world is that handsome hariya
like legit if I farted his torso with
snap I don't get it but it's just kind
of weird when they have all the plastic
surgery right to make a move and they
all look exactly the same they all do
the same like that's the format yeah
that's crazy cuz when I was in Korea I
thought I would see a ton of kpop
looking people know Korean Americans are
way more beautiful oh that's all I could
say
[Music]